[Musica]
l'unico modo per me di essere umana e
che tu mi rifletta indietro la mia
stessa umanità
la tua presenza e significativa
avevo 23 anni
studiavo architettura a Milano
lui Però l'avevo conosciuto al mare
d'estate
suonava la chitarra cantava per me
mi faceva ridere spesso
riflessa nei suoi occhi Ero tutto quello
che non riuscivo a vedere di me
mi faceva sentire unica e speciale
non è strano che quella sia stata la
prima volta in cui mi sono innamorata
Ma è stato decisamente uno shock
violento scoprire che quell'amore mi
avrebbe spezzato le ali
lasciandomi Priva di ogni capacità di
volo per anni e anni
quando le telefonate si sono
intensificate io le ho scambiate per un
segno di attenzione
un'attenzione così grande che quando mi
ha chiesto di non uscire per aspettarle
A me è sembrato naturale accettare
poi c'era questo tatuaggio sul mio polso
destro e lui diceva che una ragazza per
bene non avrebbe dovuto avere un
tatuaggio
e io francamente non capivo
diceva che non avrei dovuto parlare così
tanto con quel suo amico Sì insomma
mettermi così tanto in mostra
E io ancora non capivo
così quando stanco di darmi spiegazioni
Ha sollevato il suo pugno Per colpirmi
io d'istinto sollevato il mio per
difendermi e poi dal nulla Un pensiero
Perché fare del male ad un'altra persona
così ho abbassato il mio braccio
sono rimasta paralizzata in piedi
lasciando che lui mi colpisse
più volte
e poi molte altre volte ancora
non ricordo i colpi
Non ricordo il male
ricordo solo un'emozione di desolata
tristezza
ero rimasta completamente vuota di me
esiliata dal mio corpo
separata da tutto il mondo intorno
non mi ero mai sentita così sola
forse anche voi nell'ascoltare la mia
storia vi starete adesso chiedendo
quello che ho cominciato a domandarmi
anch'io da quel momento in poi
perché è rimasta
perché
sono rimasta
[Applauso]
quando Ascoltiamo una storia come la mia
ci ritroviamo in bilico su un abisso
completamente esposti al lato oscuro
della nostra umanità
non c'è niente che ci prepari
all'impatto con questa dimensione
è un territorio difficile da
attraversare Ma è ancora più difficile
da abitare io le persone che subiscono
violenza e poi chi ascolta i nostri
racconti tutti cerchiamo Istintivamente
una via di fuga qualcosa dentro di noi
si agita e si aggrappa a quel che trova
pensieri dubbi domande
quando qualcuno ci racconta qualcosa che
non capiamo o che non riusciamo ad
accettare
noi smettiamo di ascoltare e cominciò a
sentire solo quello che accettabile per
noi
così ascoltando una storia come la mia
quello che possiamo fare è cominciare a
mettere tutta l'attenzione su quello che
ha fatto Chi Ha agito una violenza
indicarlo come il cattivo e cominciare a
cercare evidenze di questa nostra scelta
in quello che abbiamo ascoltato
la richiesta di non uscire per aspettare
le telefonate
il giudizio sul tatuaggio una gelosia
ossessiva
una volta individuato un colpevole chi
ascolta è già al sicuro può fidarsi
della storia c'è un carnefice che Ha
agito una violenza Il fatto è che in
questa versione della storia Chi ha
subito la violenza non potrà fare altro
che vestire i panni della vittima quasi
certamente immaginata inermene muta
impotente
Non so perché ma in modo quasi istintivo
ho sentito che sposare questa versione
della storia sarebbe stato pericoloso
per me che avrebbe compromesso la mia
capacità di superare l'esperienza
Poi però c'è tutto un altro tipo di
percorso che possiamo fare per toglierci
dal disagio di ascoltare una
testimonianza di violenza
del tutto opposto Possiamo cominciare a
mettere l'attenzione su quello che ha
fatto o che non ha fatto la persona che
ha subito la violenza Questo farà
nascere tutt'altro tipo di domande
che cosa avrà fatto ho detto per
scatenare così dal nulla una reazione
simile
una domanda come questa non è neppure
una vera domanda è piuttosto un giudizio
che implica una sentenza di colpevolezza
io
ho scelto di sposare questa versione
della storia
e ho concluso ok
me la sono cercata
la scelta di rimanere in silenzio di non
raccontare in effetti sembra confermare
questa versione della storia anche
perché sembra essere l'unica risposta
accettabile alla domanda perché è
rimasta
perché sono rimasta
avrei potuto parlare con la mia famiglia
avrei potuto condividere con amici
fidati ma non l'ho mai fatto per paura
temevo di ritrovare nello sguardo della
persona a cui avrei affidato il mio
racconto quello stesso dubbio che
abitava dentro di me quella stessa
sentenza di colpevolezza e questo vedete
sarebbe stato ogni volta peggiore della
violenza in sé
Ho scoperto solo recentemente grazie a
una ricerca condotta dalle Monde che
quello che mi è accaduto in realtà
accade al 70 per cento delle persone che
subiscono violenza
si chiama siderazione psichica
tecnicamente è uno stato di paralisi
fisica ed emotiva
di fronte a una situazione percepita
come terrificante la mente non riesce
più a gestire gli stimoli e si dissocia
l'immagine diciamo l'idea che una
persona possa battere i pugni e così
mettersi in salvo abita sicuramente il
nostro immaginario collettivo ma non
corrisponde alla realtà
La realtà è che la mente si paralizza
non hai più accesso ai tuoi confini
non è più accesso alla parola non è più
accesso a te stessa
mentre il corpo comincia a precipitare
sotto il peso di quella realtà L'anima
vola via lo abbandona per rimanere
libera
si parla di effrazione del campo
psicologico che blocca la mente
attraverso la non rappresentabilità
dell'esperienza
il fatto che quello che stai vivendo sia
così terrificante
impensabile impossibile
costituisce una minaccia troppo grande
per l'integrità mentale e psichica e la
mente stacca
le funzioni superiori che servono per
analizzare
comprendere
memorizzare e comunicare non rispondono
Non riescono più a gestire la situazione
non riescono neppure a gestire le
emozioni legate a quello che stai
vivendo
l'unica funzione a rimanere attiva e la
capacità di sentire la paura
Ecco perché sono rimasta
Ecco perché le persone che subiscono
violenza restano
ma io adesso come torno da questo esilio
fai un passo dentro e ascoltati
fa paura
sì
Ma tu ascoltati
fa male
sì
dove fa male come fa male ascoltati
respira
Ecco io è così che sono tornata a casa
per iniziare Mi è bastato sapere che è
difficile
e poi con il tempo ho cominciato a
trovare le parole e quando finalmente ho
dato voce alle mie memorie mute ho
compreso molto profondamente che gli
abusi prosperano nel silenzio e che la
parola è l'unico modo per mostrare se
non una via di fuga almeno una via
d'uscita
e tu
tu cosa puoi fare
Ma tu se puoi Ascoltami
e poi ascoltati
rimani presente a questo momento qui
adesso
a tutta l'intensità che contiene
perché vedi è qui che c'è anche tutto il
potenziale
Lo vedi C'è un vetro che ci separa
c'è un filtro davanti ai tuoi occhi c'è
una membrana che ti ricopre le orecchie
ti impediscono di vedermi e ti
impediscono di ascoltarmi ci impediscono
di incontrarci
i filtri che usiamo per colpevolizzare e
anche quelli che usiamo per vittimizzare
sono già qui prima ancora che noi
possiamo cominciare a dire o ad
ascoltare
naturalmente li usiamo per difenderci
Per non incontrare un'umanità che ci fa
orrore
Il fatto è che se non diventiamo
consapevoli di questi filtri non
potremmo fare esperienza neppure del
lato luminoso della nostra umanità
continueremo a rimanere separati e
distanti continueremo ad aspettarci che
le violenze siano quello che raramente
sono le persone che subiscono violenza
continueranno a non poter parlare e
anche quando finalmente troveranno il
coraggio di parlare non si sentiranno
ascoltate E saremo tutti
responsabili delle nostre rispettive
solitudini
insieme
Cosa possiamo fare insieme
utilizziamo le parole come veicolo per
connetterci condividiamo le nostre
esperienze ma Non fermiamoci lì
diventiamo consapevoli dei nostri corpi
delle sensazioni delle emozioni e dei
pensieri
diventiamo consapevoli dei filtri
attraverso cui guardiamo e ascoltiamo
prestiamo attenzione
partecipiamo
riduciamo la distanza tra noi e noi tra
noi e la vita Quando saremo vicini
abbastanza
cominceremo a percepire con affetto e la
nostra presenza sarà il primo
rivoluzionario gesto di cura
lasciamoci toccare dall'esperienza degli
altri Lasciamo che cambi la nostra
Allora il nostro ascolto
le nostre parole e le nostre azioni
cambieranno la sua e insieme
rivendicheremo la nostra comune umanità
dichiarando che siamo sempre di più di
quello che ci accade
E se poi cominciassimo a creare nuove
domande invece che dipendere dalle
risposte
difendere dalle risposte cercare
posizioni definire ruoli
ci fa pensare che esista un solo modo
per sistemare le cose un solo modo per
fare bene
quando ci apriamo alla vulnerabilità
alla duttilità alla tenerezza cominciamo
a scoprire nuovi modi per impegnarci nel
mondo forse non tutti saranno visibili
ma l'importante non è farsi vedere
L'importante è il dono della vista e
dell'ascolto che noi possiamo fare agli
altri grazie
[Applauso]